-Our first guest
is a two-time Emmy winner
for her work on "Modern Family."
She stars in the new film
"Mixtape,"
which premieres December 3rd
on Netflix.
Please welcome Julie Bowen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ First on,
Jul-i-i-i-i-i-i-ie ♪
♪ Julie,
in love with you, girl ♪
♪ First on, Jul-i-i-i-i-ie ♪
-Wow!
-Oh, my goodness.
Welcome!
Thank you for coming back.
Thank you for helping me out
with that bit, too.
-I really like
someone singing to me,
especially that handsome
gentleman over there.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course.
Just The Roots. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you for --
-He's like, "Look at me!
Look at me, Julie!
Look at me."
-Yeah.
-You put them right behind you.
I'm like, "Uh-huh.
That's right. Okay.
Oh, hi."
-Yeah.
I was -- I was very happy
to meet your cousins backstage.
-Yeah, that was my --
my niece and nephew.
-Oh, niece and nephews.
-My niece and nephew.
They're very tall,
so they look like my cousins.
-Very cute. Yeah.
But, I mean, I guess
you're here for
the big family Thanksgiving?
-Yeah, we're all gathering.
They have a new apartment,
so we're --
we're gonna break it in.
-Yes.
-We're gonna break --
most likely just break it.
-Yes, that's what you do.
That's what families get
together and do, yeah.
-Exactly.
Until it finally has such bad
memories, we can never go back.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you --
Are you cooking?
-Well, define "cooking."
Like, with an oven?
Not as much, no.
[ Laughter ]
I don't -- they leave me
in a corner, like,
with some greens and a knife
and I just chop things.
-Yeah.
-No, this is stuff no one eats.
-That's what I'm in charge of,
because I'm a terrible cook.
-You are a terrible cook?
-Yeah -- do you cook?
-I love cooking.
-Bull-honky-loney.
[ Laughter ]
I don't believe you.
-That's not a word at all!
-I know, but I almost --
-I'm a fantastic cook.
I was trying --
Here's -- here's why.
I cook all day.
Let someone else clean up.
That's all I want.
But that's what
I'm gonna be doing now.
-Yeah.
-I'm dish-dogging.
-Yeah, you gotta do the dishes.
-You're a dish dog.
-I don't mind doing the dishes.
-You know why?
I know why.
'Cause everybody
gets a little buzzed,
and someone gets a little angry
at the table, and you're like,
"Dishes?"
-Gotta go do the dishes.
-Yeah, let's go. Yeah.
-Let's go do the dishes.
-Sorry, gotta go.
-Sorry, Uncle Henry...
-Yeah.
-...and you're incredibly --
-Yeah, you go over there.
-Yeah.
And you go, "Yeah, I'm just
gonna go do the dishes."
-Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
-And you got me time.
Alone time, scrubbing away.
I don't mind.
-And no one gets mad at you.
They think you're a hero.
They're like,
"Jimmy, you know...
-"He went and did the dishes.
What a great guy."
-He's just the same
as he always was.
-Yeah, exactly.
-"He hasn't changed a day."
-Yeah.
-How are your kids doing?
I know you have teenagers.
You have twins.
-How old -- Wait.
How old are your kids?
-They're 8 and almost 7.
-You have girls, though.
-Yeah, two little girls.
-Two girls.
Okay, so I speak Italian
and French and a little Spanish,
but I have teenagers,
and I don't speak grunt.
[ Laughter ]
Do you speak grunt?
Are you fluent in grunt?
-No, not yet.
-No, it's like, "Hey, buddy.
I heard you got
an A on your test."
"Uh..."
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, um, where were you
all afternoon
when I couldn't find you?
You're in trouble, young man.
Come sit down."
"Uh."
It's the exact same thing.
There's no variation.
-Do you embarrass your kids?
-Oh, I try to.
I mean, do you?
-I'm feel like I'm starting
to get that phase now
where they're not laughing
at all of my jokes
like they used to.
-Yeah. Well, that's --
[ Laughter ]
-I'm like, "Oh, wow.
You're actually --
Used to you were
my best audience," like...
-No, Jimmy.
No. They hate us.
-They do.
-You know what?
They'll watch the other Jimmy
before they watch you
every night of the week.
I guarantee.
[ Laughter ]
My kids have never watched
"Modern Family"!
-Never!
-Really?
-They have watched
all of "The Office."
[ Laughter ]
Every single episode
of "The Office."
They have never watched
"Modern Family."
They will watch things and go,
"That is the coolest thing."
You know, I --
-"I was in a pretty cool thing."
-I've been on TV
for a little while.
-"I've won Emmys. I've --"
Yeah.
-Not interested.
-That's hilarious.
-They are embarrassed
and ashamed of it.
And they don't -- the oldest,
the grunter, the real grunter,
and I love you, Oliver,
but he won't be bring anybody
into the house, because he says,
and I quote,
"You'll just talk to them."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "I'll talk to them?"
And that is my worst offense.
[ Laughter ]
I will speak to them.
-"Don't -- Don't talk to anybody
when I have people over."
-"Don't --
Just don't talk to them!"
-"Just don't talk to people."
-I'm like,
"What happened to Stacy's mom?"
She was hot.
They loved going over there.
[ Laughter ]
-Stacy's mom...
-Why can't I be Stacy?
I'm not even pushing this.
-Do they love the dog?
You got a dog.
I saw --
I follow you on the socials.
Look at this cute dog.
-This was my --
That's Gertrude, Gerty,
Gertrude Stein.
-Gertrude Stein.
Oh, no.
-She is my retirement gift
to myself.
-Retirement from --
-Dating.
-Oh, from dating.
-Yeah, it's done. I'm done.
This is shut.
-Wow.
-Shut it down.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Well, you know, but you can't --
you can't go out all night.
You can't stay out.
There are no sleepovers.
And no one wants to sleep
in the bed with this.
-Well, is that, like,
a little pug?
Like, a pug mix?
-She's a -- she's a chug.
A Chihuahua pug.
-A chug is the cutest name.
I've never heard of that.
-I didn't, either.
I think it's made up.
-That is so cute.
-Yeah, and I didn't -- I said --
I'm just --
People were
trying to set me up, and --
-You're done with dating?
-I'm done with it.
And I was like --
I went on a date with a guy
who kept saying I had to go to
his house because he had a dog.
And I was like,
"I need to get a dog."
I'm gonna -- I'm gonna
control this narrative.
I'm the one with a dog,
and I'm leaving the house.
So too bad, how sad.
-But no -- but you were so fun.
I saw that you went to a -- you
went to a Harry Styles concert
the other day.
Did you bring your kids to that?
-Why would I bring my kids?
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy, they're gonna ruin it.
They would ruin Harry Styles.
When you're
in the Harry Styles --
I mean, first of all, ladies,
Harry Styles.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, yeah, of course.
I'm sure his music is splendid.
But ladies...
[ Laughter ]
And I went with an adult
female friend,
and we pretended
that he sang to us every song.
Every song.
We're like,
"He dates an older woman,
but if he's done with her,
at any point..."
[ Whistles ]
"Harry!"
-Oh, my gosh.
So you're going to his concert
to meet --
-♪ Sweet creature ♪
Yes.
-Did you -- Did you meet him?
[ Laughter ]
-No.
Because, Jimmy,
you can never meet your, like,
sexual heroes, basically.
[ Laughter ]
Can you?
Have you ever met anybody
that you were like --
Like, you were a kid,
you were like, "Bo Derek."
-Sure.
-And then you meet her,
and you're like,
"She's so nice or human."
She's not -- She's no longer --
-Oh, I see.
You want to -- You want to keep
the fandom going.
-Yeah, you got to keep
that distance.
You got to keep that --
that sparkly magic.
-Did you -- how -- I --
I just saw you, by the way,
on "Curb Your Enthusiasm."
You were so funny.
-Thank you.
-Do you know --
Did you know Larry David
before that?
-No, and I -- I'm not sure
I know him any better now.
It was during COVID,
and the man's a germaphobe.
So there was, like,
a mask that had a mask
with another baby mask
in front of it.
[ Laughter ]
He'd be like, "Hi."
-So Larry David.
-"I'm Julie, um..."
[ Laughter ]
-Great space work right there.
You did --
-Did you like it?
-You went up and around
in the mask.
It was really well done.
-Thank you.
I don't think -- but I -- I --
He was somebody
I'm always glad knowing.
-You were so funny.
You were great together.
-Thank you.
I didn't get to spend
a lot of time with him,
which was good, because,
you know, he's hot.
He's a hot dude.
I liked him.
And he's married.
-Yeah.
-You might not know this.
-I do.
-I'm single, and I was retired
from dating but I don't need --
I don't need to be around
hot single dudes right now
like Larry David.
-No. Yeah, no.
-It's gonna ruin my streak.
-No. You got --
That's why you have Gertrude.
-That's Gerty.
-That's what I'm talking --
That's why you have Gerty.
That's what I'm talking about.
-Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, I -- I want to talk to you
about your new movie
and other things
when we come back.
-More with Julie Bowen.
Come on back, everybody.